hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel i'm jillian i'm
dave welcome to the show let's do it
it's time for an adrenaline rush let's
head to england this is not just
motocross racing this is sidecar
motocross racing take a
[Applause]
look i remember the first time we got on
a start line
and it's just adrenaline blob was
pumping heart rate was racing
being on a sidecar does add the extra
dimension because you've got to work
with the person next to you
having him as my brother in the sidecar
is what it's all about
i'm sam helton i'm andy houghton we're
brothers and we're a competitive sidecar
across team
i started racing probably when i was
about 10. um i'd been on a bike since
four years old
ah there you go that's a mean look isn't
it i was
maybe 13 in that picture
sam beat me once in the last race that
we had no yeah yeah yeah
still only ever beating me once yeah
won my first championship with the local
club about 11 or 12 years old rover bike
all the way up through different
championships to i was 24 in 2005 and
that's when i had my accident
[Music]
i had an accident while i was out
training i ended up going over the
handlebars and landing flat on my back
shattered my t7 vertebrae
that one moment kind of changed my life
i came out of hospital and i spent a
couple of years without without doing
much
it's only so long that you can fend off
that desire and that bug to get back on
a bike
we found the sidecar and now i'm out
racing this thing which is fantastic
when i tell people that i race sidecar
they seem to assume that i'm going to be
the one in the passenger side but
that's not the case um i'm on the bike
the guys in the sidecar there's no
sitting there's no sitting at all
they're throwing themselves from left to
right and you've got to be fully
able-bodied
my role on the team is effectively to
turn the bike in to keep it level
to do that it's a case of chucking your
weight from side to side
if andrew wants to go one way and i'm
not on the same way then we're not going
that way
most of the time he knows what i'm going
to do as brothers you probably got that
that relationship a little bit closer
than you would otherwise
[Music]
that feeling you get when you're out on
the track
for me it's what i live for
you get it banked into a corner and
you've got the bike drifting sideways
i'm out there and no one knows that i'm
in a wheelchair no one knows
you're just one of the guys you're a
sidecar racer you're not a disabled guy
and it's just it's an amazing feeling
[Music]
jillian have you ever wanted to run away
and join the circus
yes i did i was gonna go to circus
school and i went to journalism school
instead well this young woman might have
achieved your dream for you let's take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air
it's a feeling unlike any other
you feel
power you feel
like you're in control
you feel special
that's what makes trapeze beautiful
that's what makes
the circus beautiful
[Music]
my name is kristen finley and i'm a
trapeze artist
15 years ago i was working for brewery
in los angeles
i had a great life making great money i
had you know my lexus and i had a house
i was only you know 24 years old
a friend of mine told me that she was
flying trippies and i said what are you
doing i want to come watch
i ended up taking a class
and i was hooked it was addictive
right away
and i quit my life in la and i joined
the circus
[Music]
i went from good pay to zero pay just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight
and here we are 15 years later
i never looked back and i've been on the
road ever since
to run away and join the circus it takes
commitment
you have to be ready for anything you
have to kind of
live on your toes because you never know
what's going to happen
your own personal space your rv or
whatever that's your home
and that's
what has to be stable inside
[Music]
whenever you're flying trapeze you have
to focus on what you're doing and the
moment you doubt yourself in the middle
of a trick most likely you're going to
mess up you're not going to make it
the fact that i was able to do it made
it more appealing to me i'm doing these
tricks and they're harder and they're
harder and this is awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it
anything's possible there's not too many
african-american female circus
performers but i was still able to do it
your life is what you make of it and i
wouldn't change my life for the world i
really wouldn't
[Music]
for this next story we're going to meet
a ghanaian tribal chief who's working to
bring money back home to his community
and he's doing it by working as a
landscaper in canada
just 45 minutes north of the us border
is a city called langley it's a typical
city
there's a casino tree-lined streets
and of course a ghanaian tribal chief
this is eric manu he works in langley as
a gardener for this woman susan watson
in canada yard work is a year-round
occupation you'd be surprised how busy
we are during the winter
[Music]
back to eric eric's story began with a
phone call last july yeah my uncle died
and i got a call to take over that
responsibility as a chief of my
community and dancing abroad number two
he said something like really are you
kidding me
i said i'm going to give it a try
so he went back to ghana and became
chief but he decided to return to
langley and this is when susan got
involved and where our contemporary
story begins everything that happened
after eric became chief i have seen so
much in canada as my own experience and
i also want my people to have some kind
of opportunity
in life
with susan eric is working on raising
funds and collecting donations to help
set up medical clinics for his tribe to
improve education
overall he's trying to make life better
for his people back home
we started the to the moon back
foundation to help the people in ghana
we've collected more than two 20-foot
containers full of donated items
my journey has been
a very successful journey
although i'm a chief in ghana i'm proud
working as a gardener to support and
give my people the exposure i'm proud of
my community i'm proud of my family and
i'm proud to be an african and i'm proud
to be a ghanaian
[Music]
now let's head underwater and discover
the true meaning of freedom let's go
scuba diving
[Music]
one of the coolest things is when we
take a diver with a disability in open
water
the word freedom
comes up over and over and over again
because that's how they describe
their feeling
[Music]
my name is jim elliott founder and
president of dive harp
we help people with disabilities using
zero gravity and scuba therapy
it's a great equalizer we take
their new normal in some cases and we
help create a paradigm shift so now the
individual with the disability isn't
defined by that disability
and they go into a room and people say
you do what you scuba dive that's
impossible you're in a wheelchair
a little bit
i was on my bicycle and i was struck by
a car
and i hurt my t11 vertebrae and severed
my spinal cord
i knew that all of a sudden when i lost
the feeling and the ability to move my
legs that life had changed
when i was 23 years old
i dove into a pool and i dislocated my
c67 vertebrae which led me to be
paralyzed from my neck down
i'm totally dependent from someone else
all the time
i suffer from neurological pain
and i take medication for that
but every time i get into the water i
feel better i don't feel pain for a
couple of days
so i love it
[Music]
we see immediate pain relief
individuals with everything from ms to
spinal cord injuries and cerebral palsy
can become pain free
[Music]
if we can get divers deep enough to 66
feet which is three atmospheres there's
an extra output of serotonin in the
human body the serotonin will help with
the pain management up to three weeks
it just helps their quality of life
in so many different ways you know body
mind and spirit
diving is just amazing because i get out
of this position and i can kind of do
whatever i want and get in whatever
position i want which you don't get to
do on land
when you're kind of stuck to a chair
being weightless is one of the best
feelings
i was looking at myself standing up and
that was for me
fabulous i loved it i was like oh my god
can i believe i'm seeing myself standing
up again after i imagine so many years
15 years that i got my accident
i feel like totally independent i feel
like freedom liberty out of the power
chair
it's me again
[Music]
thanks for watching these great big
stories with us
click the horse to subscribe and do not
forget to comment we'll see you next
time
you